und nun kommen wir zu unserem wirklich
erschütternden cold case yasmin stieler
wird nach einer disco-nacht ermordet
doch damit nicht genug der mörder der
zerstückelt ihre leiche und verteilt sie
in ganz niedersachsen ein
unvorstellbares martyrium für ihre
mutter rosemarie schäfer sie ist
trotzdem gleich bei uns im studio und
will sprechen denn der mörder ihrer
tochter läuft bis heute irgendwo da
draußen frei herum
mit 18 liegt das ganze leben vor einem
endlich frei sein auf eigenen beinen zu
stehen hoffnungen und träume wahr werden
zu lassen doch für yasmin stieler wird
all das nicht mehr passieren denn sie
wird ermordet
jasmin ist ein einzelkind geht auf das
lessing gymnasium im niedersächsischen
uelzen
ihre eltern haben sich gerade scheiden
lassen sie ist trotzdem ein
lebenslustiges mädchen hat einen freund
lebt sogar schon in ihrer eigenen
wohnung doch mit 18 jahren wird ihr
leben brutal beendet die schülerin
wollte in dieser nacht eigentlich nur
feiern gehen
und für sie einen mörder in die hände
der sie tötete zerstückelte und dann
hier zwischen hannover und braunschweig
die leichenteile entsorgte das ist schon
verbrechen wo man als reporter
eigentlich auch nie loslassen kann bis
heute 25 jahre nach der tat wurden noch
immer nicht alle sterblichen überreste
gefunden es fehlen noch die hände der
gymnasiasten und der täter läuft noch
immer frei herum
die einen mitnehmen die einen bewegen
mein erster ausbilder hier meine
abteilungsleiter als der in ruhestand
gegangen ist 2006 hat er in seiner
abschlussrede noch mal gesagt das
einzige was ihnen sozusagen von seinem
berufsleben noch mitnimmt und wo er
immer noch dran zu knabbern hat ist das
der fall spieler nach wie vor nicht
gelöst ist dass es ihm nicht gelungen
ist einen tatverdächtigen zu überführen
obwohl er das der mutter im prinzip
versprochen hatte
war yasmin stieler ein zufallsopfer oder
hat sie ihr mörder sie im visier steckt
hinter dieser grausamen tat vielleicht
sogar ein serientäter
für jasmins mutter zählt nur eines
endlich ihre tochter komplett beerdigen
zu können und dass der mörder gefasst
wird geburtstag weihnachten vor allen
dingen ist ganz schlimm
wo ihr auch probleme habe ist
[Musik]
sie wäre jetzt 43 inhalt habe ich
ausgerechnet hier heißt rechte sie hätte
jetzt wahrscheinlich selbst eine familie
und selbst kinder richtig ja und sie
enkelkinder ja und das ist alles das
wurde mir vom täter genommen das wurde
mir genommen
[Musik]
cornelia missling ist damals als jasmin
verschwindet chefreporterin bei der bild
hannover und so von anfang an mit dem
fall vertraut
schülerin vermisst
ermordete jasmin ein dorf geht zum
speicheltest
killer nach zwölf jahren gefasst
mörder gibt mir die hände meiner tochter
staatsanwaltschaft braunschweig
hier lagern unzählige akten zum fall
yasmin stieler auch nach 25 jahren
beschäftigen sich staatsanwalt hans
christian wolters und seine kollegen
noch immer mit dem fall mit seiner hilfe
versuchen wir diese grausame tat zu
rekonstruieren was wir sicher wissen ist
dass yasmin stieler am 15 oktober 1996
gegen 19 uhr in uelsen einer freundin
mitgeteilt hat dass sie nach
braunschweig in die diskothek atlantis
fahren will danach verliert sich im
prinzip die spur
jasmins freundin gilt als einziger
gesicherter zeugenhinweis welche strecke
jasmin gefahren welchen zug sie genommen
und wo sie ausgestiegen ist ist nicht
eindeutig belegt es gibt folgen die
wollen sie in der bahn bei vechelde
gesehen haben sie erinnern sich
besonders an das auffällige oberteil
dass jasmin trug mit einem q fell muster
aber auch hier vom braunschweiger
bahnhof gibt es zeugenhinweise dort soll
sie andere nach dem weg zur diskothek
atlantis gefragt haben ist sie vor oder
nach dem discobesuch auf ihren mörder
gestoßen ist sie ihm freiwillig gefolgt
irgendwann in der nacht vom fünften auf
den sechsten oktober 1996
verschwindet jasmin irgendwo rund um
braunschweig
sonntag der tag nach jasmins
verschwinden mutter rosemarie macht sich
sorgen sonst ruft ihre tochter immer an
will von ihr abgeholt werden doch
diesmal bleibt der anruf aus
hatte sie sich aber das was ich im
nachhinein in dem freund ihrer predigt
und der hat mich angerufen hat gesagt
dass auch mal was so jasmin ist seine
ich dachte seine wohnung
herbstferien anfang gewesen dadurch
jedoch dass sie irgendwie zu alten
bekannten ist oder sonst wo aber es
waren gewisse anzeichen da dass sie
nicht einfach so weg ist denn alle
sachen die jasmin zum verreisen braucht
waren noch in ihrer wohnung rosemarie
schäfer alarmiert die polizei
bei der suche nach der 18-jährigen
ergreifen die ermittler eine besondere
maßnahme eine beamtin zieht sich so an
wie jasmin am abend ihres verschwindens
um leute in der disco zu befragen ohne
erfolg am 14 oktober 96 macht ein mann
am bahndamm entwickelte an einer stelle
wo gartenabfälle abgelegt werden eine
schreckliche entdeckung 14 kilometer von
der disco entfernt wo jasmin feiern
gehen wollte an dieser stelle hinter mir
findet ein spaziergänger neun tage nach
dem verschwinden von jasmin einem blauen
müllsack und in diesem müllsack sind die
sterblichen überreste des mädchens ihr
vor so
die ermittler finden heraus yasmin
stieler wurde erdrosselt wo und wie
genau wissen sie nicht um sich der
leiche der 18-jährigen zu entledigen
greift der täter zu abscheulichen mittel
das heißt der täter hat jasmin getötet
und anschließend dann die leiche
vermutlich um sie besser beseitigen zu
können zerteilt
dabei sind die beine vom körper
abgetrennt worden und auch die hände im
bereich des unterarms abgetrennt wurden
schließlich ist auch der kopf oberhalb
des hauses abgetrennt worden aufgrund
der spuren an den knochen konnte
zweifelsfrei festgestellt werden dass
die knochen mit einer säge zerlegt
worden sind vorher wurde wahrscheinlich
auch ein messer benutzt um die
körperteile vom körper zu trennen
hinweise auf einen kampf oder eine
sexualstraftat finden die ermittler
nicht warum jasmins leichnam zerstückelt
wurde ist unklar
tötung ist eine sache aber was ich total
nicht verstehen wo ich auch arge
schwierigkeiten mittag mit der
zerstückelung für die heute 66-jährige
ist der fund von jasmins torso damals
erst der beginn eines langen alptraums
an diesem see in hannover werden weitere
leichenteile gefunden etwa elf tage nach
dem verschwinden von yasmin stieler
wurden in den ricklinger teilchen an
einem fkk-strand von spaziergängern ein
menschliches bein gefunden was dort im
wasser schwamm bei der nachsuche konnte
dann am nächsten tag ein weiteres bein
gefunden werden die rechtsmedizinische
untersuchung hat dann ergeben dass es
sich um die beine von yasmin stieler
handelt was weiterhin fehlt sind der
kopf und die hände die bild reporterin
begibt sich an den nächsten fundort
ein dreiviertel jahr später am 12 1994
gab es die nächste gruselige entdeckung
in diesem mordfall ein 15-jähriger junge
fand hier beim spielen im himmel bald
ein schädel es stellte sich heraus es
war der kopf von yasmin stieler auf
knapp 60 kilometern entlang der b 65
zwischen hannover und braunschweig
findet man leichenteile der 18 jährigen
seit 1996 musste rosemarie schäfer ihre
tochter drei mal beerdigen immer wenn
weitere körperteile entdeckt wurden
50000 mark belohnung also rund 25.000
euro werden damals für sachdienliche
hinweise ausgelobt doch das sowie einer
der ersten massen gentests deutschlands
liefern keine spur zum täter
bis heute sucht die polizei auch nach
jasmins sachen wo ist ihre kleidung mit
dem q fell musste ihr schwarzer rucksack
ihr schlüssel und ihr schmuck
mysteriös das fehlen der hände die
ermittler haben dafür keine erklärung
september 97 rund ein jahr nach jasmins
tod gehen die ermittler in die offensive
die polizei hängt an der bahnstrecke
zwischen hannover und braunschweig
plakate auf spricht den mörder direkt an
der torso in vechelde der kopf im
hämelerwald die beine in hannover die
hände können sie damit leben die aktion
endet ergebnislos
ein discobesuch wird der 18 jährigen
yasmin stieler zum verhängnis die
gymnasiastin will am 15 oktober 96 in
braunschweig feiern am ende findet man
ihre zerstückelte leiche entlang der b
65 richtung hannover
hat nun 90 3 jahre nach dem mord an
yasmin stieler drängte sich ja dann
plötzlich der verdacht auf sie können
ein serienmörder in die hände gefallen
sein weil in celle ein schlachter
verhaftet wurde nachdem er eine frau
getötet und zerstückelt hatte auf
ähnliche art und weise wie jasmin zu
tode kam auch er hatte die leichenteile
versenkt hat sich dann allerdings
herausgestellt dass dieser beschuldigte
für unsere tat nicht in betracht kam
zwölf jahre bleibt der fall ein
mysterium
2008 kommt wieder bewegung in die
ermittlungen ein mann gilt als dringend
tatverdächtig der bereits 99 ins visier
der ermittler geriet ein lkw fahrer aus
vechelde sein arbeitgeber meldete den
zur tatzeit
31-jährigen der fahrer soll seinen
fahrtenschreiber manipuliert haben genau
in der nacht in der jasmin verschwand
im frühjahr 2008 finden ermittler einen
spaten am arbeitsplatz eines
tatverdächtigen hier in der nähe des
bahnhofs an dem spaten sichern die
ermittler ehrt anhaftung wie sie auch am
fundort des torsos am bahndamm gefunden
wurden
dieser tatverdächtige ist am tag nach
jasmins verschwinden in auffälliger
weise von braunschweig nach duisburg
gefahren diese vater hat länger gedauert
als sie eigentlich dauern musste er hat
mehr kilometer
gebraucht als die fahrtstrecke
eigentlich beträgt und er ist dort
verdreckt erschienen was allen damals
schon komisch vorkam all das ließe sich
problemlos damit dann einklang bringen
dass er auf dem weg nach duisburg auch
noch die leiche entsorgt hat die fahnder
sammeln genügend indizien um den mann
anzuklagen
im herbst 2008 kommt der lkw fahrer in
untersuchungshaft ein halbes jahr später
soll der prozess beginnen rosemarie
schäfer ist wie elektrisiert
sehr befreiend und
hatte mich wirklich gefreut dass sie
jetzt den täter habe es gab ja eine
reihe sehr gravierender indizien gegen
ihn das ist richtig und
leider hat es dem richter am
oberlandesgericht
nicht gereicht
trotz des zudem noch widersprüchlichen
verhaltens des tatverdächtigen
familienvater
ein beispiel für dieses auffällige
aussageverhalten war dass er gegenüber
der polizei gesagt hat wenn sie mir die
tat beweisen können gebe ich sie auch zu
das ist so eine äußerung die hört man
von unschuldigen normalerweise nicht
nach dem gericht lassen die indizien zu
viel raum für mögliche andere
tatverdächtige anklage abgewiesen ja ich
bin es bodenlos runter gesagt man ist
als in allen der boden unter den füßen
weggezogen wird
die entscheidung des oberlandesgerichts
war für uns natürlich ein herber
rückschlag
es ist 12 jahre ermittelt worden durch
die polizei durch die staatsanwaltschaft
wir hatten das gefühl dass wir den
richtigen tatverdächtigen haben wir
haben auch gedacht dass wir ihn
überführen können selbst wenn man heute
noch beweise fände wäre ein neues
verfahren nicht sicher denn gegen den
angeklagten wurde nur wegen totschlags
ermittelt
wenn wir nur einen totschlag nachweisen
könnten wäre eine gerichtliche
aufarbeitung nicht mehr möglich wir
könnten allerdings einen mord
weiterverfolgen mord verjährt nie dafür
ist aber erforderlich dass wir bestimmte
mord merkmale haben wie mordlust
befriedigung des geschlechtstriebs
solche dinge
auch jetzt 25 jahre nach dem verbrechen
geben mutter rosemarie schäfer und die
staatsanwaltschaft die hoffnung nicht
auf oder auch die bild-redaktion bleibt
an dem fall dran hier die wichtigsten
offenen fragen zum fall
für uns ist wichtig wert yasmin stieler
nach dem fünften oktober 1996 19 uhr
noch gesehen insbesondere im raum
braunschweig vielleicht auch im umfeld
der diskothek artland ist wer kann
angaben dazu machen wo die
kleidungsstücke yasmin stieler das
geblieben sind insbesondere die
auffällige kuhfell jacke für hinweise
die zur rechtskräftigen verurteilung des
täters führen gibt es eine belohnung von
70.000 euro
20 jahre her aber ich möchte dass der
mörder meiner tochter gefasst wird dann
ist mein stärkstes anlegen meine tochter
komplett bekommen helfen sie mit jasmins
mörder zu fassen noch ein appell an den
täter selbst
ich gebe keine ruhe man sieht sich ja
und bei uns im studio ist jetzt
rosemarie schäfer vielen vielen dank
dass sie die kraft und stärke aufbringen
heute bei uns zu sein wir haben uns
gerade zusammen den film angeguckt haben
ihre tochter gesehen sie war damals 18
jahre alt ja was was für pläne hatte sie
für ihr leben die pläne waren in so
einer kiste die man mir ein paar jahre
später überreicht hat was in der schule
gefertigt worden ist jeder der
mitschüler hatte so was und da wurden
zettel rein gemacht und nach dem ersten
klassentreffen wurden diese kisten
geöffnet man hat sie mir gebracht und
der stand eben halt drin dass sie in die
forschung wollte
pharmaforschung sie hat ja auch schon
bald präsidiums kontakt aufgenommen also
tiermedizin forschung was war sie für
ein mädchen
ja ein sehr offenes aufgeschlossenes
selbstbewusstes mädchen aber trotzdem
auch ich sag mal schutzbedürftig und
dann eines tages hat die kriminalpolizei
an ihrer tür geklingelt erinnern sie
sich noch an diesem tag das ging über
mehrere tage weil es waren ja merkmale
zu dem zeitpunkt wusste ich das ja nicht
dass sie in einzelteile war
deswegen nachmittags loskam anruf
montagnachmittag
dieses körpermerkmal jenes wichtig beim
dritten anruf gesagt jetzt sage ich
nichts mehr jetzt kommt ihr und dann
wurde mir das erzählt haben sie da
direkt gespürt das was ja da gibt es
eine verbindung ich weiß nicht mutter
tochter verbindung ich kann es nicht
beschreiben jedenfalls ich hab's gespürt
dann kamen die beamten was was genau
haben die ihnen gesagt und wie haben sie
darauf reagiert die haben es mir gesagt
aber ich war denn in einem film ich weiß
bis heute nicht was ich dann gemacht
habe ganz nicht rekonstruieren wir
auf dem grab ihrer tochter auf dem kreuz
wir haben ein foto gesehen da steht
warum ja das möchte ich dir mehr da
tragen weil was ist was es ihre eine
erklärung kann es ja ähnlich geben aber
ihre theorie ihr gedanke warum musste
ihre tochter sterben ich kann es nicht
sagen also das wollte ich ja meine mama
dessen
25 jahre sind jetzt vergangen seitdem ja
dann kommt man da nie zur ruhe oder ist
ihre tochter jeden tag bei ihnen die ist
jeden tag präsent und man lernt ich sage
damit umzugehen
wir helfen so zufrieden wie kann man mit
so etwas umgehen ich habe fünf jahre
aktiv in traumatische bahnen und hinter
mir und man lernt mit sowas zu leben es
kommt mal mehr mal weniger hoch aber man
lernt damit zu leben
haben sie jetzt hier heute noch hoffnung
dass der mörder der ovo da draußen rum
läuft noch gefasst werden kann ja die
hoffnung stirbt ja zuletzt und schon
allein deswegen weil ja mittlerweile die
belohnung erhöht worden ist auf 75.000
und ich kann nur immer wieder an die
bevölkerung appellieren wenn jemand sich
dann noch daran erinnert
gibt hinweise die zur rechtskräftigen
verurteilen für und wir haben uns im
vorfeld natürlich mit profiler mit
beamten mit ermittlern und erhalten was
macht bei einem fall der so lange
zurückliegt sinn was können wir beitrag
und da war eben ein ganz klarer satz na
ja wenn da draußen der täter noch sitzt
dann kann ebenso einen beitrag so ein
foto auch eben wenn die mutter im studio
ist wenn die mutter spricht bei ihm
auslösen nach all den jahren doch ein
geständnis abzulegen oder wenn es
mitwisser gibt wenn die das hören das
ding da war doch was da habe ich doch
mal was gehört wollen sie vielleicht
einmal direkt in diese kamera
adressieren an menschen die mit höheren
die mit gucken oder an den mörder ihrer
tochter was wollen sie denen sagen gerne
in diese kamera
wenn du es mit seinem gewissen
vereinbaren kann dann melde dich stehe
dazu was du gesagt hast denn ich gebe
keine
vielen dank und sehr sie haben es gehört
unser marie schäfer gibt keine ruhe
danke danke dass sie heute bei uns waren
und diese stärke wirklich mitgebracht
haben und wir alle hoffen eben dass der
mörder noch geschnappt wird und endlich
hinter gittern kommt deswegen helfen sie
rosemarie schäfer helfen sie der familie
und der polizei in niedersachsen haben
sie doch noch hinweise nach all den
jahren zb können sie sich an dieses
markante t shirt mit dem q fell muster
was wir vorhin auch im beitrag gesehen
haben erinnern dann kontaktieren sie die
polizei zum beispiel in braunschweig
unter 0531
476 2516
war schäfer nochmal vielen vielen dank
dass ihr bei uns waren